This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2015 the world was divided into two warring factions seemingly overnight and at the center of this schism was a single photograph. Social media is exploding this morning with a debate about one dress. The simple question is what colors do you see black and blue or white and gold? It's blue and black. It is white and gold. It's blue and black. I really see white and gold. It's blue and black. It's finally time for me to break my silence. I see white and gold.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2015年，世界一夜之间似乎分裂成了两个交战阵营，而这场分裂的核心是一张照片。今天早上，社交媒体上关于一条裙子的争论炸开了锅。一个简单的问题是：你看到的颜色是黑色和蓝色，还是白色和金色？是蓝色和黑色。是白色和金色。是蓝色和黑色。我真的看到的是白色和金色。是蓝色和黑色。我终于要打破沉默了。我看到的是白色和金色。
If you've been living off the grid and under a rock, I'm here to tell you that once upon a time, a photo of a dress took over the internet. In 2015, Cecilia Blesdale took a picture of a dress that she planned to wear to her daughter's wedding, and that photo went so viral that it literally slowed down the internet. If you haven't seen it yet, Google it because depending on how your brain works, you either see it as blue with black trim or white with gold trim with absolutely no room in between for debate. But back in 2015, while the rest of us were a big ring over black versus white versus
如果你一直与世隔绝，两耳不闻窗外事，那我得告诉你，曾几何时，一张裙子的照片席卷了互联网。2015年，塞西莉亚·布莱斯代尔拍下了一张她打算在女儿婚礼上穿的裙子的照片，这张照片在网上的传播速度之快，甚至让互联网都变慢了。如果你还没看过，去谷歌搜一下，因为根据你大脑运作方式的不同，你要么看到的是蓝色配黑色饰边，要么是白色配金色饰边，中间完全没有讨论的余地。但在2015年，当我们在为黑色对白色，还是
blue versus gold, science writer Adam Rogers knew this story was way more than just a popular meme. You could tell that the biggest story in the country for the next eight hours was a science story, and it was a science of vision and neuropsychiatry and neurobiology and color. This is Adam, by the way, he was working as the science editor at Wired at the time. We just knew it had to be ours, and we also knew that everyone else would now be thinking of this as a science story, because the first story was the meme story. The first story was check out this dress that everybody thinks is two different colors, and immediately was the first thing that you say when that happens, the first thing you
蓝色对金色争论不休时，科学作家亚当·罗杰斯知道这个故事远不止是一个热门模因那么简单。你可以看出，未来八小时内全国最大的新闻是一个科学故事，它涉及视觉、神经精神病学、神经生物学和色彩的科学。顺便说一下，这就是亚当，他当时在《连线》杂志担任科学编辑。我们当时就知道这必须是我们的报道，我们也知道其他人现在会把它当作一个科学故事来思考，因为第一个故事是模因故事。第一个故事是“看看这条裙子，每个人都觉得它是两种不同的颜色”，而当这种情况发生时，你说的第一件事，你对自己说的第一件事就是：为什么？
say to yourself is why. Adam recently wrote a book called Full Spectrum, of a science of color made us modern. Today I'm going to be talking to him about how the pursuit to organize, understand, and create colors has been one of the driving forces shaping human history, starting with the dress. So could you tell me where you were and what you were up to the first time you saw a picture of the dress? It was the end of the day at Wired and this you know this meme came across everybody's desk I guess I should acknowledge upfront. I'm a little sugary to say I did not think much of it
亚当最近写了一本书叫《全光谱：色彩科学如何塑造了现代世界》。今天我将和他探讨人类为了组织、理解和创造色彩而进行的追求，是如何成为塑造人类历史的驱动力之一的，我们就从那条裙子开始。那么，你能告诉我你第一次看到那条裙子的照片时，你在哪里，在做什么吗？那是《连线》杂志下班的时候，这个模因出现在了每个人的桌面上，我想我应该先承认一下。我有点不好意思说，我当时没怎么在意。
In the picture first showed up. I thought huh. That's what I thought huh, but then a palamine That's what I thought. But then a palamine, a guy who was the executive editor, came and kind of plopped down next to me just to kibbit, as is the God-given right of all journalists. And we both kind of say, you see this dress thing? It's crazy, huh? This dress thing.
照片刚出现的时候。我想，嗯。我当时想的是“嗯”，但后来帕拉明，那个执行编辑，走过来坐在我旁边闲聊，这是所有记者的天赋人权。我们俩都说，你看到这个裙子了吗？太疯狂了，对吧？这个裙子事件。
And it's like, yeah, that's crazy. And he just said, it's obviously white. And I went, Rob, it's blue, man. And he looked at me like I was insane. And I looked at him, like he was insane. And I'm not kidding, at that exact instant, the guy who edited the website at the time, Joe Brown, came running across from the other side of the building
就像是，是的，太疯狂了。他只是说，它显然是白色的。我说，罗伯，它是蓝色的，伙计。他看着我，就像看疯子一样。我也看着他，就像看疯子一样。我不骗你，就在那一瞬间，当时负责网站编辑的乔·布朗，从大楼的另一边跑了过来，
where his desk was and like his mouth opened to make the first half of the word have to scream have you seen right and before he could even make the hat sound I yelled across the room were on it. So like optical illusions or even auditory illusions, they're all over the internet. The illusion where you see like two faces or a vase or that, the duck of the rabbit. Or you duck in a rabbit. What was it about the dress that stirred up so much debate? What, why did it slow down servers across the world?
也就是他办公桌所在的地方，他张开嘴想喊出那个词的前半部分，想尖叫“你看到了吗？”，在他还没发出那个音之前，我就隔着房间大喊：“我们正在处理！”所以，像视错觉甚至听觉错觉，它们在互联网上随处可见。那种你看到两个脸或者一个花瓶的错觉，或者鸭子和兔子的错觉。或者你是鸭子还是兔子。关于这条裙子，到底是什么引起了如此大的争论？为什么它让全世界的服务器都变慢了？
How is it unique to this particular optical illusion? I have a hypothesis about what I think the most important thing was. And it's that the illusions that you just mentioned were all the illusions of form, even if they're bimodal, which is to say they look one way and then the other way. Our brains tend to flip in between them. They flip back and forth. You stare it for long enough and you see one and then the other and then one and then the other. But illusions of color, we don't. You're bringing kind of chose one and then locked in. And then when somebody else would say they saw the other
它对这种特定的视错觉有什么独特之处？我有一个关于我认为最重要的一点的假设。那就是你刚才提到的那些错觉都是形式上的错觉，即使它们是双稳态的，也就是说它们看起来是一种样子，然后又是另一种样子。我们的大脑倾向于在它们之间切换。它们来回切换。你盯着看足够久，你会看到一个，然后是另一个，然后又是一个，再是另一个。但色彩的错觉，我们不会。你的大脑选定了一种，然后就锁定了。然后当别人说他们看到了另一种
one, that just seemed insane. It was like somebody was saying, no, obviously people walk on the ceiling and then if they fall, they hit the floor. It's like, no, people walk on the floor. Or, you know, like it just, if somebody saw the way that you didn't, there was no, there was no crossing the gap. It was impenetrable. It was either you were correct or you are insane. And there was no middle ground between them, which is why great debates on the internet happen.
的时候，那看起来简直不可理喻。就像有人在说：“不，显然人们是在天花板上走路，如果他们掉下来，他们会撞到地板。”就像是，不，人们是在地板上走路。或者，你知道，如果有人看到的和你不一样，根本没有，根本没有跨越鸿沟的可能。它是不可逾越的。要么你是对的，要么你是疯了。它们之间没有中间地带，这就是为什么互联网上会发生激烈的争论。
That's right. And also the stakes were so low. OK, so then let's get into it. What is happening here? Why does it seem like it's white and gold or blue and black to different people? Right. Well, so to get into that, you have to first understand that when we see colors, when we talk about colors, we're talking about two related but separate properties. Now,
没错。而且风险也很低。好吧，那我们深入探讨一下。这里发生了什么？为什么对不同的人来说，它看起来像是白色和金色，或者是蓝色和黑色？对。嗯，要深入了解这一点，你必须首先明白，当我们看到颜色，当我们谈论颜色时，我们谈论的是两个相关但独立的属性。现在，
obviously what we're talking about are photons or electromagnetic waves bouncing off of a thing and then bouncing into our eyes. So that's true. That's a thing that happens. That's physics. But surfaces will have a color, and then there's a color of illumination. There's light that's hitting those surfaces. And when we see colors, what are our eyes and our brains are doing a calculation essentially that combines those two things. And effectively tries to subtract the color of the illumination from the surface so that you can say what the surface color objectively is. That is an ability called color constancy. And so this, for example,
显然我们谈论的是光子或电磁波从物体上反射出来，然后射入我们的眼睛。所以这是真的。这是一件发生的事情。这是物理学。但表面会有颜色，然后还有照明的颜色。有光照射在这些表面上。当我们看到颜色时，我们的眼睛和大脑实际上是在进行一种结合了这两者的计算。并有效地试图从表面减去照明的颜色，这样你就可以说出物体表面的客观颜色是什么。这是一种被称为“色彩恒常性”的能力。所以，例如，
if I'm in a room with white walls and I know it's a room with white walls and I put a red light bulb in it, I don't think those are red walls. I think those are white walls, but they just look red to me because there's a red light bulb in the room. Yeah, that's exactly right. I would even invert it and say, if you see a picture of an egg,
如果我在一个有白墙的房间里，我知道这是一个有白墙的房间，我在里面放了一个红色的灯泡，我不会认为那是红色的墙。我认为那是白色的墙，只是因为房间里有个红色的灯泡，它们对我来说看起来是红色的。是的，完全正确。我甚至会反过来说，如果你看到一张鸡蛋的照片，
but it's red, you don't go, oh, a red egg. You say, oh, an egg with a red light shining on it. Yeah, exactly. Now, the two examples that both of us just used there are two of the hypotheses for how the brain creates color constancy. The ability to see an object is having the same color under different illuminations. So that's what's going on. If your brain is trying to figure out what color is the light and what color is the object. Okay. The image taken on a phone, so with a sensor in 2015 that wasn't great, that wasn't really good at figuring out what the color of light was and what the color of the object is, seen on screens, so with light being emitted in two people's eyes
但它是红色的，你不会说，哦，一个红色的鸡蛋。你会说，哦，一个被红光照射的鸡蛋。是的，完全正确。我们俩刚才用的这两个例子，是关于大脑如何创造色彩恒常性的两个假设。即在不同照明下将物体视为具有相同颜色的能力。所以这就是正在发生的事情。如果你的大脑试图弄清楚光是什么颜色，物体是什么颜色。好的，这张照片是用手机拍摄的，所以传感器在2015年并不好，它不太擅长分辨光的颜色和物体的颜色，在屏幕上观看，所以光是从屏幕发射到人们眼睛里的，
from the screens, not as a reflective surface as you would see on an absorbative surface as if you were looking at a photograph, let's say. And, and this is the key thing, what time of day was it? So because of the way the kind of the background of the photograph looked like it was lit, which was very brightly lit. Your brain could make a decision.
而不是像你看着照片时那样，从反射表面或吸收表面看到的。而且，这是关键点，当时是什么时间？因为照片背景看起来被照亮的方式，是非常明亮的照明。你的大脑可以做出一个决定。
Unconsciously, your brain would decide, am I looking at a picture that was taken at high noon when the color of the light that's ambient light outside is bright yellowish white? Or am I looking at something that was taken in the afternoon? And so if you thought that the photograph was taken in mid-day, then the illuminance was white and the color of the dress was blue. But if you thought that the dress was in shadow,
潜意识里，你的大脑会决定，我是在看一张正午时分拍摄的照片吗？那时室外的环境光是明亮的黄白色？还是我在看一张下午拍摄的照片？所以如果你认为这张照片是在中午拍摄的，那么照明就是白色的，裙子的颜色就是蓝色的。但如果你认为裙子是在阴影里，
or when the sun was lower in the sky, then you thought, that's a white dress in some sort of shadow, that what I'm seeing as blue is actually just the color of the light around it. So the mind makes that decision and sticks to it. With a lot of visual illusions, you either see the duck or the rabbit or the old woman or the young woman,
或者当太阳在天空中较低时，那么你会想，那是一条在某种阴影下的白色裙子，我看到的蓝色实际上只是周围光的颜色。所以大脑做出了那个决定并坚持下去。对于许多视觉错觉，你要么看到鸭子或兔子，要么看到老妇人或年轻女子，
but there's no correct answer because it's both, like it's designed to be both. What's interesting about the dress is that half the people who say they saw white and gold were just wrong. I think we can agree that people who saw white were bad people. I think that's fairly clear to me. They're people who should be shunned, I think, broadly, but what you've identified there
但没有正确答案，因为它是两者，它被设计成两者。关于裙子有趣的是，有一半说他们看到白色和金色的人就是错了。我想我们可以同意，看到白色的人是坏人。我认为这对我来说相当清楚。他们是应该被排斥的人，我认为，广义上来说，但你所指出的
is that the problem is that there really is a dress. There is a dress exists. That dress exists and it is blue. It was made to be blue. It's dyed blue. It's There is a dress exists. That dress exists and it is blue. It was made to be blue. It's dyed blue. It's made of a blue textile. It's made of a textile that has the properties of being blue. So it's a blue dress. But as soon as you were looking at a reproduction on a computer screen of an image taken with a digital camera and also honestly the color scientist really will say, look, ultimately, the color that you perceive is a function of the photons interacting with the
是问题在于真的有一条裙子。有一条裙子存在。那条裙子存在，而且它是蓝色的。它被制作成蓝色。它是染成蓝色的。它是由蓝色纺织品制成的。它是由具有蓝色属性的纺织品制成的。所以这是一条蓝色的裙子。但一旦你是在电脑屏幕上观看用数码相机拍摄的图像的复制品，而且老实说，色彩科学家真的会说，看，最终，你感知的颜色是光子与
surface and then the way that your brain and eye process those colors. A bumblebee looking at the same object would see it as a different color because they have different photoreceptors. Their eyes work differently. Their brains work differently. So who's right? Is the bumblebee right or am I right? No, I mean, there's a color. If there's a thing, it has a color. It's a real thing.
表面相互作用，然后你的大脑和眼睛处理这些颜色的方式的函数。一只大黄蜂看着同一个物体，会把它看作不同的颜色，因为它们有不同的光感受器。它们的眼睛工作方式不同。它们的大脑工作方式不同。那么谁是对的？是大黄蜂对，还是我对？不，我的意思是，有一种颜色。如果有一个东西，它就有一种颜色。它是一个真实的东西。
If you stop believing that, then you're having a philosophical conversation. It's an important one, but it's a different one. But the question of how our brains and eyes make those colors for us, even when we do it the same way, even if you and I see the same color there, it's an interesting question of why we do it the same way. So the general public was very excited about this. You and all the folks at Wired were very
如果你不再相信这一点，那你就是在进行哲学对话。这是一个重要的对话，但它是不同的。但关于我们的大脑和眼睛如何为我们制造这些颜色的问题，即使我们以同样的方式做，即使你和我看到同样的颜色，为什么我们以同样的方式做，这是一个有趣的问题。所以公众对此非常兴奋。你和《连线》的所有同事都非常
excited about this. What did the color scientists of the world think about this? What did they take from this? It was existential for them. So the scientists start trying all of the kinds of experiments that you would imagine that you would want to do. My favorite work was actually getting the dress, the real dress. So these researchers actually got the dress and set it up in a room with black walls, basically like a black box theater. And then set up the lighting in the room with tunable LED lights. One of the things that happens when human beings see light is that it can create, if there's combinations of wavelengths, you can create something called a metimer. So you can have one kind of light, you can have one
兴奋。世界上的色彩科学家对此有何看法？他们从中得到了什么？这对他们来说是存在主义的。所以科学家们开始尝试所有你能想象到的你想做的实验。我最喜欢的工作实际上是拿到那条裙子，真正的裙子。所以这些研究人员真的拿到了裙子，把它放在一个有黑墙的房间里，基本上就像一个黑匣子剧院。然后用可调的LED灯设置房间的照明。当人类看到光时，会发生的一件事是，如果存在波长的组合，你可以创造出一种叫做“同色异谱”的东西。所以你可以有一种光，你可以有一种
wavelength of light, but also a mixture of wavelengths that looks the same. And to our eye and our brain, they're indistinguishable. This is one of the key differences between seeing color and listening to music, let's say. When we listen to music, we hear all the individual wavelengths, we hear all the notes, and then they combine together in euphonias and harmonious ways, right? Like they've become chords, but that doesn't happen with light. It combines into one thing. And that can fool us into, so we're not sure what we're really looking at. So what they did in this room was you would think you were seeing the dress under white light.
波长的光，但也可以是一种看起来一样的波长混合物。对我们的眼睛和大脑来说，它们是无法区分的。这是看到颜色和听音乐之间的关键区别之一。当我们听音乐时，我们听到所有的单个波长，我们听到所有的音符，然后它们以悦耳和和谐的方式结合在一起，对吧？就像它们变成了和弦，但这在光中不会发生。它结合成一个东西。这会欺骗我们，所以我们不确定我们到底在看什么。所以他们在那个房间里做的是，你会以为你在白光下看到裙子。
And white light is equal amounts of every wavelength. But in fact, they would drop some wavelengths out, which alters the way that you perceive the object, but in an imperceptible way. And they found that they could control what color people reported, seeing on the dress, that they could force the card. They could make people see it as white or make people see it as blue or make people see it as really any color they wanted, which will keep you up at night if you're a color scientist.
而白光是每种波长的等量组合。但事实上，他们会去掉一些波长，这会改变你感知物体的方式，但以一种难以察觉的方式。他们发现他们可以控制人们报告在裙子上看到的颜色，他们可以强行改变结果。他们可以让人们把它看作白色，或者让人们把它看作蓝色，或者让人们把它看作他们想要的任何颜色，如果你是一个色彩科学家，这会让你彻夜难眠。
I mean, you compare the dress and the book to the Rosetta Stone saying it may allow scientists to decrypt the corners of human perception and psychological color space. What do you mean by that? When we talk about color, we think we're talking about the color of an object. We have an object in our hand and it has some color that's intrinsic to it or intrinsic to its surface. And then if we really, if we think harder about that, we know we're also talking about something in physics, we're talking about something subatomic, photons are waves that are bouncing off of that thing and bouncing into our eyes.
我的意思是，你把裙子和这本书比作罗塞塔石碑，说它可能让科学家解密人类感知和心理色彩空间的角落。你是什么意思？当我们谈论颜色时，我们以为我们在谈论物体的颜色。我们手里有一个物体，它有一种内在的颜色，或者其表面内在的颜色。然后如果我们真的，如果我们更深入地思考这个问题，我们知道我们也在谈论物理学中的东西，我们谈论的是亚原子层面的东西，光子是波，从那个东西上反射出来，射入我们的眼睛。
And then if we think even harder about that, we know we're talking about, well, actually, we're talking about the way that these sensors built into our skulls process that information and transduce it into neuro-electrical signals that then goes into the meat that we think with and then gets re-translated into some vision of the world, literally a vision of the world that we have. And so that's the hardest anybody can think about this problem. But because it's happening inside our brains, because it's part of our, the process, our
然后如果我们更深入地思考，我们知道我们谈论的是，好吧，实际上，我们谈论的是嵌入我们头骨中的这些传感器处理该信息并将其转换成神经电信号的方式，然后进入我们思考用的肉体，然后被重新翻译成某种对世界的视觉，字面上是我们拥有的对世界的视觉。所以这是任何人能对这个问题思考的最深程度。但因为它发生在我们的大脑内部，因为它是我们的一部分，这个过程，我们的
creation of mind, it's influenced by who we are and how those brains developed, how the brain developed and how our specific brain developed. So there's these successive iterations of perception that if you can either take them all apart, figure out how they relate to each other, you can begin to understand culture, begin to understand the development of the brain, begin to understand how the brain works, and how the brain takes these signals from outside, takes what are objective signals from, I mean, there really are photons out there,
心灵创造，它受到我们是谁以及这些大脑如何发展的影响，大脑如何发展以及我们特定的大脑如何发展。所以这些感知的连续迭代，如果你能把它们拆开，弄清楚它们是如何相互关联的，你就可以开始理解文化，开始理解大脑的发展，开始理解大脑是如何工作的，以及大脑如何从外部获取这些信号，获取客观的信号，我的意思是，外面确实有光子，
there really are electromagnetic waves, there really are objects, there really are those things, but we process them through our senses, and try to make sense of them. So understanding that, when you get an opportunity like the dress, that separates people into different categories, depending on how they do this,
确实有电磁波，确实有物体，确实有那些东西，但我们通过感官处理它们，并试图理解它们。所以理解这一点，当你得到像裙子这样的机会时，它根据人们如何做这件事将人们分为不同的类别，
you begin to understand, you can ideally begin to understand how all of those things work. The color white has been so impactful on human history that Adam devoted three whole chapters of his book to it, and we're going to spend the rest of the episode talking about one of those stories. The 1893 Brawlts Columbian Exposition, also known as the White City. Some of you might recognize it from Eric Larson's book called Devil in the White City, but
你开始理解，你理想情况下可以开始理解所有这些东西是如何工作的。白色在人类历史上影响巨大，以至于亚当在他的书中用了整整三章来写它，我们将用本集的剩余时间来讨论其中一个故事。1893年的哥伦比亚博览会，也被称为“白城”。你们中有些人可能从埃里克·拉尔森的书《白城恶魔》中认出它，但是
the whole serial killer part of the White City tends to overshadow the design aspect. Adam tells me about how this event was a powerful example of how color and architecture could be more than just aesthetic choices, but tools of asserting cultural dominance. The Chicago World's Fair, 1893 basically, the 2, 3, four. Really is this kind of picked over well, picked over fair for architecture, design fans, because the color and design of it are so much part of the story of American hegemony at the time. So by the time this world's fair happened, there had been several in Europe and they were grand successes. And especially one in Paris where they built this beautiful tower that people probably heard of or like the one in London where they built the Crystal Palace and their gorgeous exhibition halls and people would go all over the world they would show up and
白城的整个连环杀手部分往往掩盖了设计方面。亚当告诉我，这个事件是如何成为色彩和建筑不仅仅是审美选择，而是主张文化统治的工具的一个有力例证。芝加哥世博会，1893年，基本上，2、3、4。对于建筑和设计爱好者来说，这确实是一个被翻来覆去研究的博览会，因为它的色彩和设计在很大程度上是当时美国霸权故事的一部分。所以当这次世博会举行时，欧洲已经举办了几次，而且都取得了巨大的成功。特别是巴黎的那一次，他们建造了人们可能听说过的这座美丽的塔，或者像伦敦的那次，他们建造了水晶宫，还有他们华丽的展览馆，人们会从世界各地赶来，他们会现身，
they were, you know, these things were like educational and theme parks and also trade fairs all rolled into one thing and they really showed off the cities and the way that everybody always hopes like an Olympics will these days. And so in the US with the anniversary of Christopher Columbus arriving on the North American continent, or at least within ships through the North American continent, there was this desire in the US to celebrate that and also to celebrate what was seen
它们就像教育和主题公园，也是贸易博览会，集于一身，它们确实展示了这些城市，就像每个人今天都希望奥运会能做到的那样。所以在美国，随着克里斯托弗·哥伦布抵达北美大陆的周年纪念，或者至少是船只抵达北美大陆，美国有一种愿望来庆祝这一点，也来庆祝被视为
as this signal American achievement of having made it all the way across the continent of the fulfilling that the that manifest destiny that everybody thought was the right of the white people, the white men who were running the country at the time. So then the questions became, well, how do you celebrate that and where do you solve what do you do? And finally, after some competition, the city that really was kind of the center of American culture, physically really the center of American culture,
这种标志性的美国成就，即一路穿越整个大陆，实现了每个人都认为是当时统治国家的白人、白人男性的权利的“昭昭天命”。所以问题就变成了，好吧，你如何庆祝这一点，你在哪里解决，你做什么？最后，经过一些竞争，真正成为美国文化中心，物理上确实是美国文化中心，
physically really, the center of American culture at the time, one was Chicago, which went out over these East Coast cities, there were the oldest cities, one out of New York and Boston, Philadelphia, whatever, mostly because it was the center of this vast rail network and the center of the American consumption of protein and a place where more people could come, but also because it was the, I mean, you could make the argument. It was the great city at that moment in the United States, partially because it was where the architects, famous architects were working on inventing the skyscraper.
物理上确实是当时美国文化中心的城市，一个是芝加哥，它胜过了这些东海岸城市，那些最古老的城市，胜过了纽约、波士顿、费城等等，主要是因为它是一个庞大的铁路网络中心，是美国蛋白质消费的中心，是一个更多人可以来的地方，但也因为它，我的意思是，你可以提出这个论点。它是当时美国伟大的城市，部分原因是因为它是建筑师、著名建筑师致力于发明摩天大楼的地方。
This thing that we define cities all over the world by now is first being worked out in its most basic scheme by by specifically some architects, who then were the ones who got assigned to figure out the world's fair, this world's exposition. So you have these names of people who have a significant imprint on the American built environment, all working together in Chicago,
这个我们现在定义世界各地城市的东西，最初是由一些特定的建筑师在最基本的方案中构思出来的，他们后来被指派去负责世博会，这次世界博览会。所以你有这些对美国建筑环境有重大影响的人的名字，都在芝加哥一起工作，
you have Daniel Burnham, who was the main exponent of the city, beautiful movement, to make no small plans, was the famous phrase always attributed to him, and his partner, John Root, and Frederick Law, Olmsted, Freshoff, his triumphant plans for parks, like the Amal Mechless in Boston, Central Park,
你有丹尼尔·伯纳姆，他是“城市美化运动”的主要倡导者，“不做小计划”是归功于他的名言，还有他的合伙人约翰·鲁特，以及弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德，他那辉煌的公园规划，比如波士顿的翡翠项链，纽约的中央公园，
in New York, all coming together to figure out how are we gonna do this thing that's going to celebrate the American achievement? It's almost as if they were trying to design what uniquely American architecture should look like in the first place. Like, did they ever figure that out? I mean, what did they end up building? Well, they made a set of decisions that all, like, one sort of progressed from another,
所有这些都汇聚在一起，想出我们要怎么做这件事来庆祝美国的成就？这几乎就像他们试图设计出独特的美国建筑最初应该是什么样子。就像，他们弄明白了吗？我的意思是，他们最终建造了什么？嗯，他们做了一系列决定，所有这些，就像一个接着一个，
but they made, the first decision they made was they said, we'll have this classic Olmsteadyen paths and hills and interaction between water and land. And in the center of it, there will be a court of architecture where we will celebrate the best of architecture that we have to offer. And all the other stuff, the fun stuff we're going to put off to the side. But in the middle part, they were going to have the court of honor, like the most, all the pavilions. And they decided that they didn't want the pavilions
但他们做出的第一个决定是，他们说，我们将拥有这种经典的奥姆斯特德式的路径和山丘，以及水与陆地的互动。在它的中心，将有一个建筑庭院，我们将在这里庆祝我们所能提供的最好的建筑。而所有其他的东西，有趣的东西，我们将放在一边。但在中间部分，他们将拥有荣誉庭院，就像最，所有的展馆。他们决定他们不想让展馆
to just look like the Crystal Palace had. They didn't want them to just be temporary looking metal and glass structures. They had to have solidity and they had to show permanence and they had to show dominance and control. They had to show that Americans had nailed it. Man, the Americans got it right. And the way that they were gonna show that was unclear
看起来就像水晶宫那样。他们不想让它们只是看起来临时的金属和玻璃结构。它们必须具有坚固性，它们必须展示持久性和统治力与控制力。它们必须展示美国人已经做到了。伙计，美国人做对了。而他们展示这一点的方式是不明确的
because there was so much work to do. And they finally had to like hire in all the other architects in the country, essentially, like the folks from McIntyne, Mead and White, which is the famous New York firm. And initially in the meetings, root especially, Burnham's partner did some drawings that were very fanciful and was kind of more
因为有太多的工作要做。他们最终不得不雇佣全国所有的其他建筑师，基本上，比如来自麦金、米德和怀特事务所的人，这是著名的纽约事务所。最初在会议上，鲁特特别是，伯纳姆的合伙人做了一些非常奇特的图纸，而且更
ish-influenced and red-brown brick. And then all the architects from the East Coast came out for a big meeting. It's a full and it's kind of moreish influenced and red brown brick. Then all the architects from the East Coast came out for a big meeting. In the beginning of that meeting, Rute wasn't feeling that well by the middle of that meeting, Rute had pneumonia. Before that meeting was over, over the course of about a week, Rute had died. And Burnham kind of lost it, but he just couldn't believe that they had come this close, together to like recreating the American built form together and then, you know,
偏向摩尔风格，红棕色砖。然后所有来自东海岸的建筑师都出来参加了一个大型会议。在那个会议开始时，鲁特感觉不太好，到会议中期，鲁特得了肺炎。在那个会议结束之前，在大约一周的时间里，鲁特去世了。伯纳姆有点崩溃了，但他简直不敢相信他们已经如此接近，一起重新创造美国建筑形式，然后，你知道，
it's snatched away from them. But Burnham did have something in common with these other architects who he brought in, which is they were all basically trained in this four, the Bozart's School of Architecture, which had come to emphasize a certain style inflected by what they believed the architecture of ancient Greece and Rome to have looked like. So, the fact that the capital building in Washington looks like a Greek temple, that's this. That is neoclassical architecture, totally.
它从他们手中被夺走了。但伯纳姆确实与他带来的这些其他建筑师有一些共同点，那就是他们基本上都受过这种布杂艺术建筑学院的训练，该学院强调了一种受他们认为古希腊和罗马建筑风格影响的特定风格。所以，华盛顿国会大厦看起来像希腊神庙，这就是这个。那完全是新古典主义建筑。
But together, they decided that the way to convey this validity that they wanted to convey the permanence, the glory of Rome would be to go too hard and back to the glory of Rome, to the imperial architecture as a style. And they decided it would all match. They said everything on the court of honor would all have the same height. It would all be built and that style we're going to build. Everything that way, and I was all fake, it was all like, imagined-eared, because inside these buildings, they would look just like the crystal pearls.
但他们一起决定，传达他们想要传达的这种坚固性、持久性、罗马荣耀的方式，就是回到罗马的荣耀，回到帝国建筑风格。他们决定这一切都要匹配。他们说荣誉庭院上的所有东西都要有相同的高度。它们都将以那种风格建造。一切都那样，而且全是假的，全是想象出来的，因为在这些建筑内部，它们看起来就像水晶宫。
They would just be metal and metal frames and glass. But on the outside, they would use this kind of plaster like stuff called staff, and they would make these forms that would look like they were carved out of the Tarato marble of Italy or whatever. But then they still had a decision to make, which was, okay, well, what are we going to, what's the surface going to, what's the surface treatment going to be? And they talked about stuff like a sort of kind of beige brown. They ignored a truth that I have convinced myself at least that they would have known at the time,
它们只是金属框架和玻璃。但在外面，他们会使用这种叫做“staff”的石膏状材料，他们会制作出看起来像是从意大利卡拉拉大理石雕刻出来的形式。但他们仍然有一个决定要做，那就是，好吧，我们要，表面处理会是什么？他们谈论过像一种米棕色之类的东西。他们忽略了一个事实，我至少已经说服自己，他们当时肯定知道，
which is that those buildings, when they weren't neoclassical, but were in fact classical, when the Greeks and Romans built them, they were very colorful, highly chromatic. All the reds and yellows of the ochres and some blues and greens, the insides would have had harlequin and checkerboard patterns.
那就是那些建筑，当它们不是新古典主义，而是实际上是古典主义时，当希腊人和罗马人建造它们时，它们是非常多彩的，高度彩色的。所有的红色和黄色赭石，还有一些蓝色和绿色，内部会有丑角和棋盘图案。
The archaeological evidence at the time that existed even showed that, and the Bowsarts people, the people who trained in the Bowsarts architectural school actually would travel to Athens and to Rome and paint these things. I've seen these images that they painted when they brought back for school assignments and they had all the colors on them. Some people still don't believe they're like, well, maybe that's just, you know, function of age. That's just like you know, function of age. That's just like liking or something growing on it.
当时存在的考古证据甚至显示了这一点，而布杂艺术的人，那些在布杂艺术建筑学院受训的人，实际上会去雅典和罗马，并把这些东西画下来。我见过他们带回学校作业时画的这些图像，上面有所有的颜色。有些人仍然不相信，他们说，好吧，也许那只是，你知道，年代久远的结果。那只是，你知道，年代久远的结果。那只是像地衣或什么东西长在上面。
There were arguments about it. So they went with what they ended up saying was like, okay, well, the court, everything that symbolizes, everything that is, they were gonna have all these exhibits at the fair of everything, all technology through history. So like the transportation building was gonna have, every mode of transportation that had ever been built, or the textile building, whatever,
关于这一点有争论。所以他们选择了他们最终所说的，好吧，那么，庭院，象征着一切，一切都是，他们要在博览会上展示所有的东西，历史上所有的技术。所以像交通大楼将会有，曾经建造过的每一种交通方式，或者纺织大楼，无论什么，
every kind of loom ever, they would have everything ever and what they the guy who was doing the catalogs Came from the Smithsonian Describe this is being an object lesson everything would be an object lesson being object that would have a lesson to it It would have a catalog this would be like the card catalog like every item would be the real actual item and also be a lesson about the development of that item So the the design of the fair itself, of the Court of Honor, the architecture, that was its own object lesson. They were saying this is a country
每一种织布机，他们会有曾经有过的所有东西，而那个负责目录的人来自史密森尼学会，描述这是一种“客体教学”，一切都将是一个客体教学，会有教训。它会有一个目录，这就像卡片目录一样，每一项都将是真实的实际物品，也是关于该物品发展的教训。所以博览会本身的设计，荣誉庭院，建筑，那本身就是一个客体教学。他们是在说这是一个国家
that harkens the tradition of Rome and Greece, and in fact, it is the white men who run it. And it really is that direct, right? Like this idea of the cultural weight of whiteness and that all other color was sinful including pigments of skin and, you know, like it really, it's foregrounded. That I think that's something that I think much like the colorful, you know, facades of Greek classical architecture. I think people have a hard time recognizing how foregrounded the symbolism is to the whiteness.
它呼应了罗马和希腊的传统，事实上，是白人男性在经营它。而且它确实是那么直接，对吧？就像这种白人文化的重量，以及所有其他颜色都是罪恶的，包括皮肤的色素，你知道，它确实，它是被突显出来的。我认为这就像希腊古典建筑的彩色外墙一样。我认为人们很难认识到这种象征意义对白人来说是多么突出。
I tend to have some insensitivity to this kind of symbolism. You know, when I read, I'm like, oh, that was the sled symbolizes a childhood. You know, like, I've missed that stuff. Here, it's so blatant. Yeah. They literally took everything of color and put it on the midway. There's one important exception, which is that every architect or architect's team
我往往对这种象征意义有些迟钝。你知道，当我读的时候，我会想，哦，那雪橇象征着童年。你知道，我错过了那些东西。在这里，它是如此公然。是的。他们字面上把所有有颜色的东西都放在了中途岛。有一个重要的例外，那就是每一位建筑师或建筑师团队
got assigned one of these buildings. And Burnham and Rute were rightly seen at the times being some of the parents of the idea of the skyscraper. The other parents, the skyscraper, one of them was an architect, and Louis Sullivan. Sullivan was another Chicago architect, and he came in and got assigned the transportation building. Sullivan had not been trained in the Bozart School. He'd been trained in a whole other school of architecture that grew out of a kind of weird romantic polychromatism
都被分配了其中一栋建筑。伯纳姆和鲁特在当时被正确地视为摩天大楼理念的父母之一。摩天大楼的另一位父母，其中一位是建筑师，路易斯·沙利文。沙利文是另一位芝加哥建筑师，他进来并被分配了交通大楼。沙利文没有受过布杂艺术学院的训练。他受过另一种建筑学院的训练，这种学院源于一种奇怪的浪漫主义多色主义，
that had come out of Europe and textile work a couple hundred years before. And so he built this riot of color slightly off the court of honor of the transportation building. Mm-hmm. Sullivan's revolution, his chromatic revolution, I think is the one that actually obtained. It's the only building that really had it influence.
这种主义在几百年前从欧洲和纺织工作中产生。所以他在交通大楼的荣誉庭院外建造了这个色彩的狂欢。嗯。沙利文的革命，他的色彩革命，我认为是真正获得成功的。它是唯一真正产生影响的建筑。
Everything else sort of faded away by the 20s. architectural critics were saying, whoa, we're thinking, we gotta try something else. It helps give rise to modernism in architecture is the rebellion against the same way that sort of punk in new wave, where, you know, rebelling against sort of the pop classism of disco in a weird way, like the architecture rebelled against that except for the transportation building, the public, the transportation building became much more of a touchstone. Yeah, because by the time you get to the 1901 World's Fair, it's all a celebration of polychromy. It's just like fashion and design and everything of the modernism is born and it is multi-gullar. Right, and two things happen. One of them is the cultural shift. One of them I think is an understanding,
其他一切在20年代都逐渐消失了。建筑评论家们说，哇，我们在想，我们得尝试别的东西。它有助于引发建筑现代主义，是对那种方式的叛逆，就像朋克和新浪潮，你知道，以一种奇怪的方式反抗迪斯科的流行古典主义，就像建筑反抗那个，除了交通大楼，公众，交通大楼成为了更多的试金石。是的，因为当你到达1901年世博会时，这完全是对多色主义的庆祝。就像时尚和设计以及现代主义的一切诞生了，它是多色的。对，而且发生了两件事。其中之一是文化转变。其中之一我认为是一种理解，
like, well, look, this country is not going to just be monochromatic in its approach, in who the immigrants are, and who runs things. It's going to be more than that. By then, already, Chicago itself was the place where the Great Migration was going to be centered around. It was not just a white city.
就像，好吧，看，这个国家在方法上，在移民是谁，谁经营事情上，不会只是单色的。它会更多。到那时，芝加哥本身已经是大迁徙将要集中的地方。它不仅仅是一个白人城市。
It was an every-color city. And also the technology chain. So in addition to new pigments becoming available and becoming more available to designers and architects, the other thing that happened were electric light. And once electric light comes in, it becomes literally a whole different way of seeing the natural world outside. You start to see a whole different kind of colors projected onto surfaces. In fact, initially the Paris fair, that was the city of lights thing, it had been a gas
它是一个全色城市。还有技术链。所以除了新颜料变得可用并变得更容易被设计师和建筑师使用之外，发生的另一件事是电灯。一旦电灯出现，它就字面上成为了一种观察外部自然世界的完全不同的方式。你开始看到投射在表面上的完全不同种类的颜色。事实上，最初的巴黎博览会，那是“光之城”的东西，它一直是一个煤气
lamp thing, experience, but then becomes electrical. Chicago was heavily electrically lit. In the early decades of the 20th century, have things like Hoover Dam starting to provide electrical power to places on the west that can start to eliminate their streets. You get neon lights out there. You get a much more polychromatic experience that combines both the service pigment treatments and also the color of light shining on them at night. And people can see colors outside at night that they have never seen before. Yeah. Yeah.
灯的东西，体验，但后来变成了电气的。芝加哥被大量电气照明。在20世纪的最初几十年里，有像胡佛大坝这样的东西开始为西部的地方提供电力，可以开始照亮他们的街道。你在那里得到霓虹灯。你得到了一种更丰富的多色体验，结合了表面颜料处理和晚上照在它们上面的光的颜色。人们可以在晚上看到他们以前从未见过的颜色。是的。是的。
I don't know why maybe I just have the wrong priors here, but when I think of all the sciences of the world, you know, I think of know why maybe I just have the wrong priors here, but when I think of all those sciences of the world, you know, I think of physics, I think of chemistry, the business of color doesn't seem like the preoccupation of serious people or something. I know I know this is wrong. I know it's totally wrong, but I had no idea how preoccupied people were with color. And, you know, as you describe it, it really is, in many ways, the first formal science. And not only that, but it's kind of human kinds first science at all because they're making ochre, zeta, dirt, and stone, and stuff like this. I mean, understanding how it really is fundamental to science.
我不知道为什么，也许我只是有错误的先验知识，但当我想到世界上所有的科学时，你知道，我想的是物理学，我想的是化学，色彩的生意似乎不是严肃的人的关注点之类的。我知道我知道这是错的。我知道这完全是错的，但我不知道人们对色彩有多么全神贯注。而且，你知道，正如你所描述的，它在许多方面确实是第一门正式科学。不仅如此，它还是人类的第一门科学，因为他们正在制造赭石、泥土、石头之类的东西。我的意思是，理解它确实是科学的基础。
It forces you to grapple. It forces scientists for the history of human science. It forces them to grapple with fundamental questions. It forces them to try to figure out, well, okay, we see these different colors, what are they made of? And they turn out to be made of the basic subsistix. If you're trying to apply colors to a surface, and you want to understand how to do that better,
它迫使你努力。它迫使科学家在人类科学史上。它迫使他们去处理基本问题。它迫使他们试图弄清楚，好吧，我们看到这些不同的颜色，它们是由什么组成的？结果它们是由基本物质组成的。如果你试图将颜色应用到表面，并且你想了解如何更好地做到这一点，
that turns out to require you to understand the basics of chemistry. If you're trying to understand how the brain turns sense perceptions into mind, you turn to colors as the proxy to understand that because there are things that the brain does that it's not only a metaphor, it's an actual thing that gets turned into a perception and gets turned into a sense of the world. And so at every moment, to me, I could sort of go to every moment that were the beginnings of these multiple fields of basic science and find the person who got there by studying color. You get to, you know, James Clerk Maxwell
那需要你了解化学的基础知识。如果你试图了解大脑如何将感官知觉转化为心灵，你转向颜色作为理解这一点的代理，因为大脑所做的事情不仅是一个隐喻，它是一个实际的东西，被转化为感知并被转化为对世界的感知。所以每一刻，对我来说，我可以去到这些基础科学的多个领域的开端的每一刻，并找到通过研究颜色而到达那里的人。你得到，你知道，詹姆斯·克拉克·麦克斯韦
on the way to figuring out electromagnetism is working with color. John Dalton on the way to figuring out atomic theory for atoms, on the way there is trying to figure out color blindness and color. All the way back to this cave in South Africa, where archaeologists find 80,000 year old's workshop just for making paint. Because it's so important that there's a special place to do that that they preserve.
在探索电磁学的过程中，人们开始研究颜色。约翰·道尔顿在探索原子论的过程中，试图弄清楚色盲和颜色的奥秘。追溯到南非的一个洞穴，考古学家在那里发现了一个8万年前专门用于制作颜料的作坊。因为这非常重要，所以他们专门开辟了一个地方来保存它。
This episode was produced by Vivian Leigh. After the break, Adam Rodgers comes back to tell me what the world's first color wheel was made of. You're in for a cool story. So, one of the things that people were preoccupied with when it came to color was how to organize an order color. I'm intrigued by the earliest known example of a colored wheel and what it was made of and what it was made for. Can you describe that to me please? The very first physical color wheel.
本期节目由薇薇安·李制作。休息之后，亚当·罗杰斯将回来告诉我世界上第一个色轮是由什么制成的。你将听到一个很酷的故事。人们在研究颜色时，最关心的问题之一是如何组织和排列颜色。我对已知最早的色轮例子以及它的材质和用途很感兴趣。你能为我描述一下吗？那个最初的物理色轮。
People have been trying to put colors in order. It was a preoccupation of Aristotle and Plato and all of the Greek philosophers and then the early Arab philosophers tried to figure out what a color order is because you don't understand. There's all these colors. Are they a sequence?
人们一直试图将颜色按顺序排列。这是亚里士多德、柏拉图和所有希腊哲学家关注的问题，后来早期的阿拉伯哲学家也试图弄清楚什么是颜色顺序，因为人们并不理解。这里有各种各样的颜色。它们是一个序列吗？
How does one become the other? What is that transition like? Why is it different for light than for pigments? All these things are really hard questions. One of the very first ones, the earliest kind of known illustrated version of one of these is actually a line of glass vessels full of different shades of yellow liquid,
一种颜色是如何变成另一种颜色的？这种过渡是什么样的？为什么光和颜料的过渡方式不同？所有这些都是非常困难的问题。其中最早的、已知最早的图解版本，实际上是一排装满不同深浅黄色液体的玻璃容器，
which are urine. It was doctors trying to diagnose ailments by the color of a person's urine. And so it would be like from clear to dark brown, or I guess blue if you have porphyry or something, but like blue to dark brown, like how what's could be wrong with this person? And you needed some kind of objective metric
也就是尿液。这是医生试图通过尿液的颜色来诊断疾病。所以它会从清澈到深褐色，或者我想如果你患有卟啉症之类的，可能会是蓝色，总之是从蓝色到深褐色，就像是这个人可能出了什么问题？你需要某种客观的衡量标准，
to say like, oh, we're in the sort of dark yellow version that maybe too much of the wrong humor or something like that. So yes, it's just a diagram of P. The thing that I love about this though, I think it's super cool to me about this is that in order to make these Make the artwork of the drawing the the actual physical object were these flasks that, if you're in a lab today, you call it a boiling flask. It's like a sphere with a little stem at the top of it.
来判断，哦，我们处于深黄色版本，可能体液失调之类的。所以是的，这只是一个尿液图表。但我喜欢的一点是，我觉得这非常酷，为了制作这些艺术品，这些绘图，实际的物理对象是这些烧瓶，如果你今天在实验室里，你会称之为沸腾烧瓶。它就像一个球体，顶部有一个小颈。
And being able to make those kind of accurately make a sphere out of glass, is it technical skill, glass blowing thing that people learned how to do. But before there were prisons, these glass globes, sort of goldfish-ball things, full of liquid, were an early optic technology. And it was looking at the way that light moved through these that allowed the Arab translators and scientists, like from the 300s to the 1100s, to understand correct and expand on the early optics work
能够准确地用玻璃制作出球体，这是一种技术活，是人们学会的玻璃吹制工艺。但在棱镜出现之前，这些装满液体的玻璃球，就像金鱼缸一样，是早期的光学技术。正是通过观察光线穿过这些球体的方式，使得从300年到1100年的阿拉伯翻译家和科学家们能够理解、纠正并扩展早期的光学研究，
of Aristotle and planning, folks like that. Because they were translating this work and it didn't make any sense and they were wrong about everything. So they did the experiments themselves and they used these glass spheres full of liquid to see how light moved and to understand what came to be refraction, to understand that that's that a rainbow could form by multiple refraction through drops, through raindrops, because these spheres, these same spheres that eventually would be, like in the 11 hundreds or whatever, were used to store urine and look at the color of it, were the thing that let them make a proxy for a single drop of water and figure out the movement of light.
比如亚里士多德和托勒密等人的著作。因为他们在翻译这些著作时发现它们根本讲不通，而且他们对一切的理解都是错误的。所以他们亲自做了实验，利用这些装满液体的玻璃球来观察光是如何移动的，从而理解了后来所谓的折射，理解了彩虹可以通过雨滴的多次折射形成，因为这些球体，这些最终在1100年左右被用来储存尿液并观察其颜色的球体，正是让他们能够模拟单个水滴并弄清光线运动的东西。
It's not just a pee joke. It's not. That's okay. the pee joke. That's so good. Adam Rogers' book is called Full Spectrum of the Science of Color Made Us Modern. We only scratch the surface of what he covered in the book, so if you want to nerd out about color with atoms and more, and I highly recommend that you do that, you should definitely check it out.
这不仅仅是一个关于尿的笑话。真的不是。没关系，这个关于尿的笑话太棒了。亚当·罗杰斯的书名为《全光谱：色彩科学如何塑造了现代世界》。我们只触及了他书中内容的皮毛，所以如果你想和原子以及更多内容一起钻研色彩，我强烈建议你这样做，你一定要去看看。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Le, mixed in tech production by Jim Riggs, music by our director of Sound, John Rial. Dilling Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Coles, that is the digital director. The resident includes Chris Barube, Joe Rosenberg, Lachem Adon, Christopher Johnson, Emmith Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
本周的《99%隐形》由薇薇安·李制作，吉姆·里格斯进行技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监约翰·里亚尔创作。执行制片人是迪林·霍尔，数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯。常驻人员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、乔·罗森伯格、拉切姆·阿顿、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米斯·菲茨杰拉德、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马斯。
We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or come on Instagram and write it to. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. T-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t- There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram上关注我们。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目以及《99%隐形》的每一期往期节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。